getting home can often be a tricky task
for sadiq ali this was solid land a few
days ago but the landscape here in this
remote part of the Indian state of Assam
often changes Sadiq says he's lived on
the state's River Islands his whole life
but soil erosion and rising tides have
forced him to move within the area 14
times now he and his family are faced
with a new threat to their sense of home
a government list known as the National
Registry of citizens that will decide
whose Indian and who's not and though
Sadiq is on the list it splits his
family right down the middle five in
five out and if it stays that way
half of his family including his wife
will be considered illegal immigrants
from Bangladesh I feel bad because my
wife and children are excluded they are
my family members and we have been in
this place for generations my father was
on the last list in 1951 we have all the
documents if someone says were from
somewhere else it is painful I feel bad
about it more than 30 million people
live in a sound but around 4 million
were left off the latest draft like
Sadiq and his family many are members of
a Bengali Muslim minority it's unclear
what exactly will happen to those left
off the final list but among the
possibilities are detention or
deportation Sadiq says he'll do
everything in his power to ensure his
family is not split up and though he
can't read or write he knows these
documents are all he has to prove their
links to India but life on asam's River
islands can be isolating there are no
government or social services nearby so
Sadiq travels to the mainland in search
of answers and help to fight for his
family here he visits an NGO assisting
people not on the list
these activists want to give Sadiq and
others hope but they also believe a Thor
--'tis are intent on targeting the
Bengali community comparisons have been
made with the beginnings of the Rohingya
crisis
me on my dare I feel the Bengali Muslims
and Bengali Hindus of Asama are being
targeted and excluded from the list it
seems there is an insider conspiracy
nobody talks about it but there
certainly is one but Abhijeet Sharma one
of the original petitioners for the
registry to be updated projects the idea
it is singling out minorities he
believes the issue is one of illegal
immigration they're illegal
they entered the country illegally and I
don't think that there is anything about
human rights Human Terrain for this
illegal immigrants for the genuine
Indians there may be some human rights
but for illegal immigrants usually
migrants what human rights there is
nothing about human rights but back on
the river Island those left off the list
feel life as they know it is at risk
they'll have a final chance to appeal
but aren't sure how and when it will
come with India's Supreme Court yet to
decide on the process for now there's
nothing they can do but wait and see
where the shifting sands might take them
next